so one of the world's largest reaction
YouTubers Sniper Wolf has seemingly
doxed another YouTuber Jack's films and
they weren't exactly on the greatest of
terms to begin with we know where you
liveing we came to torment you now one
of the unwritten rules of online flame
Wars is that what's said on the internet
stays on the
internet but if an online adversary were
to say move your dispute from the
internet to the real world by making an
unannounced visit to your home address
late at night then posted a picture of
set home to millions of their followers
while demanding that you two should talk
well that's the kind of thing that might
alarm a reasonable person and perhaps a
person whose home was shared with
millions of people might wonder aloud if
crimes have been committed in the
process and that person might reach out
to say I don't know your favorite legal
YouTuber and that legal YouTuber might
then go down the entire Rabbit Hole to
figure out if any crimes have been
committed here and no this is not a law
school hypothetical as much as it is a
description of the rapidly escalating
feud between two online adversaries Jax
films and Sniper Wolf now Jax films a
YouTuber and sketch median has long been
critical of fellow YouTuber and live
streamer Sniper Wolf that's sniper with
three capital s's for what he describes
as her stealing from other creators by
reposting content without permission and
creating non-transformative reaction
content a few weeks ago I made a video
about YouTuber sniperwolf and how she's
profited off the works of thousands of
other creators by reacting to them in
the laziest way possible in fact she's
gotten so predictable that Twitter user
pasur 3 made us a bingo card out of
Sniper Wolf isms and we just kind of ran
with it no shaky cam oh your boy got
shaky cam what's wrong with you stop
yelling it's kind of unnecessary got
their car their neighbor's car oh all
right summarizing sound effect that's a
take on the electric Porsche yes Mr
Beast captions huh I just got this crazy
feeling of deja vu and Sniper Wolf with
over 30 34 million followers on YouTube
and nearly 350,000 on Twitch deny
stealing content writing on Twitter
quote 90% of what I upload are my ideas
people copy me and then people like you
get confused now as much as I would like
to weigh in on whether she is stealing
content or not that is not why we are
here today no after a year of sparring
online Sniper Wolf showed up to the Los
Angeles home of Jack's films and his
wife and proceeded to share a photo of
their residence to millions of her
Instagram followers though she quickly
deleted that post Jack's films accused
us his online Nemesis of doxing stalking
and making his family feel unsafe in
their own home but mainly we feel
violated we know longer feel safe in our
own home Jax films has publicly called
on YouTube to demonetize sniper Wolf's
channel for the Post which would prevent
her from generating revenue on her
videos Sniper Wolf has denied any
wrongdoing arguing that Jax films has
defamed her by accusing her of doxing uh
Sniper Wolf also claimed that Jack's
films far from being a victim was the
one who had been harassing her by making
numerous videos that accus her of
stealing content with lazy reaction
videos this guy's entire channel is just
me me me every single video for the past
few months has been about me sniperwolf
then suggested that she might have to
get a restraining order against him so
now we have two content creators who
have viciously accused each other of
various civil and criminal violations so
the question is who is correct here and
since none of them run their own
successful YouTube channel I'm happy to
answer this question now for those of
you who aren't terminally online Jack
Douglas known professionally as
jacksfilm is a YouTuber known for his
satirical comedy videos and parodies one
of Jax film's first viral videos was the
w2f blanket a parody of the Snuggie
which garnered millions of views and was
featured on CNN well morons now there's
hope with the new what the blanket the
blanket that'll ruin your sex life he's
also the host of a pair of web series
yesterday I asked you and your grammar
sucks and since joining YouTube in 2006
Jax films has gained over 5 million
subscribers and on the other side of the
fight is Aaliyah Leah shales AKA Sniper
Wolf a streamer and content creator
since launching her YouTube channel in
2013 Sniper Wolf has acquired over 34
million followers on YouTube and
millions more of fans across Tik Tok
Instagram and twitch uh sniper Wolf's
channels feature a variety of content
such as video game character cosplays
anime video game live streaming Etc and
while her gaming videos earned her
back-to-back Nickelodeon Kids Choice
Awards for favorite gamer Sniper Wolf is
perhaps best known for making videos in
which she reacts to other people's
content that stupid idea of yours it's
never going to take off I won't be
caught dead wearing a cheap bag like
this now this epic Feud finds his roots
in April of 2022 following reports that
sniperwolf and her then boyfriend had
purchased a $7 million mansion in
Arizona in October of 2022 jackfilms
released a video entitled sniperwolf
announcing that he had launched a
secondary YouTube channel called Jax
films with three capital JS because he
was so inspired by her reaction videos
imploring his audience to help me get a
mansion too and reality this secondary
YouTube channel which states credit to
the creators in the bio is predominantly
dedicated to criticizing and parodying
Sniper Wolf for what Jax films
characterizes as profiting off of other
creators work through lazy reaction
videos responding on Twitter Sniper Wolf
dismissed Jack films criticism writing W
I can't stand that a female YouTuber is
getting more views than me even though I
make the same content G life is hard as
she then writes that quote no one ever
attacks the male react channels and
suggests people like Jax films are
envious of her success and while Jax
films has directed a lot of criticism
towards Sniper Wolf he's also long been
a vocal opponent of lazy reaction videos
famously going after now ex YouTuber
Jinx nearly a decade ago who was famous
for making lazy reaction content before
it was officially lame yo Jinx that was
a dope ass video man that was just Hella
Tight I really like the part where you
played my video in its entirety and then
didn't really react to it just kind of
sat there and more recently Jax film has
gone after singer turn Tik Tok star
Jason Derulo if you've ever heard a song
of his you'd know it because he says his
name all the time
Jason but after a year of fighting
online the pairs Feud spilled into the
real world on October 13th Sniper Wolf
posted an Instagram story asking her
millions of followers quote should I go
visit Jack's films he lives 5 minutes
away from my shoot and in another
Instagram post sniper will posted a
photo of Jax film's Los Angeles home
from the outside imploring him quote
let's talk like adults and despite
quickly deleting the post Jack films was
shocked and alarmed to learn in the
middle of live stream that Sniper Wolf
had showed up to his house late at night
shut
up 5 minutes ago posted wait what she's
literally right outside your oh my God
this is happening
right call the
police wait what and after the stream
ended Jax films ripped into Sniper Wolf
on Twitter accusing her of having doxed
him by posting a photo of his home on
Instagram while describing the incident
as creepy gross and violating quote what
you do is disgusting you steal content
and you stalk YouTubers now if your
privacy has been invaded by a YouTuber
you're going to want a great lawyer in
my firm the eagle team can help if
you've been in a car crash dealt with
sexual harassment or suffered from
cancer or have a loved one who did we
can help represent you or help find you
the right attorney it's so important to
get a lawyer right away to make sure
that you get a full recovery just click
on the link that's in the description
for a free consultation with my team
because you don't just need a legal team
you need the eagle team the link is
below the following day Jax films
recorded a video expressing his outrage
about the pre night's events last night
Sniper Wolf a massive YouTuber showed up
outside of our home recorded a video of
our home and then posted it to her 5.6
million Instagram followers goting me
with the line let's talk like adults in
my 17 years on YouTube I've never once
had someone come to my home and vaguely
threaten me Jack's wife Aaron also
voiced her concerns writing that Sniper
Wolf took a video of the house and
alleged that she quote posted it on her
Instagram for all to see with the
intention of trying to quote instigate a
confrontation quote I now have to worry
about what she as one of your favored
creators or one of her many fans may do
to harm me or my family uh she then
pleaded for YouTube to take action to
help the Douglas family and quote keep
us safe then firing back at Jack's film
Sniper Wolf denied wrongdoing while
asserting that uh his videos attacking
her content was tantamount to harassment
quote this creep has been harassing me
for months then plays victim saying I
threatened him when I just wanted to
talk to him I have no ill intentions
it's so sad when people have to
constantly create drama to pay bills and
Jax films mock sniper Wolf's claim that
she had no ill intentions quote Sniper
Wolf you showed up to our home tonight
and filmed it for your 5 million plus IG
followers to see that's called doxing
after sniper Wolf's posting of and visit
to the Douglas family home many content
creators were outraged by her actions
and affirmed their support for Jack's
films feels like the most immature
irresponsible use of power in the world
so Jax films has accused Sniper Wolf of
doxing him which he described on Twitter
as quote a literal crime well in meane
form in her defense sniperwolf claims
that she has no idea how to dox anyone
and then suggested Jax films could not
be doxed because he had allegedly posted
his address on Google so uh what is
doxing and is it a crime well in general
doxing refers to the act of publishing
identifying information about a third
party online without a victim's
permission and colloquially there are
generally two types of doxing one
involves releasing truly private
information and the other is releasing
information that is publicly available
but not widely disseminated or accessed
and while deleting the photo that Sniper
Wolf took was probably the right move uh
the internet is forever so the image
almost certainly exists somewhere so is
doxing illegal well to give everyone's
favorite answer it depends the release
of publicly available and legally
obtained information is generally not a
crime in fact doxing itself is not
specifically illegal in most us
jurisdictions but if doxing is done with
malicious intent to injure individuals
could be prosecuted for a variety of
crimes such as stalking or harassment
and doxing can also violate the private
terms of service of other platforms like
YouTube potentially resulting in
demonetization or deplatforming but
interestingly California does have an
anti-d doxing law now Jax film's Home
which sniper wol visited and briefly
posted a video of on the Internet is
located in Los Angeles and to determine
if any crimes or torts have been
committed we have to analyze the conduct
under California law in California in
also known as indirect internet
harassment is illegal if it rises to the
level of cyber harassment as outlined in
California pet code section 653.8rpm
by a third party electronically
distributes publishes emails hyperlinks
or makes available for downloading
personal identifying information
including but not limited to a digital
image of another person or an electronic
message of a harassing nature about
another person which would be likely to
incite or produce that unlawful action
okay that is a mouthful but that's not
the end of it because a personal
identifying information is not really
defined by that statute but likely under
the right circumstances it could include
things like posting the target's
residential address digital images of
the Target phone number information
about their family and so on and under
the statute harassment is defined as a
knowing and willful course of conduct
directed at a specific person that a
reasonable person would consider a
seriously alarming seriously annoying
seriously tormenting or seriously
terrorizing the person and that serves
no legitimate purpose now here Jax films
and his wife have both stated that
sniperwolf posting a video of their
house has made them feel unsafe and fear
retaliation by her fans but their
subjective belief is not the end of the
inquiry what a reasonable person feel
the same way uh of course there's a
difference between a photo of someone's
house and actually posting the address
itself that could make a big difference
here and then there is the requirement
for imminent action which probably stems
from the Constitution and the First
Amendment and the fact that they haven't
received this kind of harassment at
least none that I'm aware of at the
moment after this alleged doxing might
show that it did not in fact rise to the
level of imminent action from the people
that were viewing this post of course no
one wants their home address to be on
the internet especially in a public
forum and especially if you have some
level of celebrity but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it rises to the
level of the Cyber harassment statute
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
once it's public uh something bad is
immediately going to happen Sniper Wolf
is already making light of the situation
as if stalking someone is a quirky thing
to do but of course even if the fear of
Jack film family is shown to be
reasonable and that's definitely
possible uh the statute requires that
the information was posted with the
purpose of imminently causing that other
person unwanted physical contact injury
or harassment and so far everything that
Sniper Wolf has said online about this
incident seems to indicate that she
didn't intend for any of this to happen
she just didn't quite understand all the
ramifications of what she was doing uh
but did not intend harassment here I'm
sorry for what you're going through and
then on top of it there are legitimate
First Amendment considerations just
because you post something on Instagram
doesn't mean that you don't enjoy robust
First Amendment protections to publicize
the things that you want to publicize so
when the government makes it illegal to
disseminate certain information they run
right up against the First Amendment and
it's likely that Sniper Wolf enjoys some
amount of protection to make these kinds
of posts and that's why there are such
uh strict requirements for the Cyber
harassment statute now all that concerns
the first kind of doxing where you
publicize information that is otherwise
public but there's still the kind of
doxing where you publicize a private
fact uh Jax films could try to argue
that the briefly posted photo of their
home constitutes an invasion of privacy
and maybe in the colloquial sense but
probably not in the legal sense in
California there is a cause of action
for public disclosure of private
information that requires a public
disclosure of a private fact which would
be offensive and objectionable to the
reasonable person and which is not of
legitimate public concern and if
sniperwolf had posted something truly
private they might have a claim but I
wait that the outside of your house and
possibly even your address doesn't
qualify as private for the purposes of a
claim of invasion of privacy and looking
to one of California's most famous
failed invasion of privacy suits which
also involves a photo of a celebrity's
home online suggests an action would be
doomed uh for example in May of 2003
actress Barbara Stan sued photographer
Kenneth Adelman for invasion of privacy
for displaying a photo of her clifftop
home in Malibu on his website
documenting the coastline of California
she demanded $10 million in damage
images and that the photographer removed
the photo of her Mansion immediately
from his website but a judge threw out
the case in December of 2003 ruling that
the photo did not invade stren's privacy
and that the photo was protected speech
concerning a matter of public interest
the judge also deemed the lawsuit in
effort to silence the photographer
speech in violation the state's anti-s
slap law and ordered Babs to pay his
legal fees and ironically stren's
efforts to remove this photo had the
unintended effect of drawing more
attention to it resulting in nearly
420,000 people visiting the
photographer's website to view the image
two years later Mike maznik of tech dirt
dubbed the phenomenon of unintentionally
bringing unwanted attention to something
you'd rather suppress the strian effect
and now you too know the atmology of the
Strand effect so photos of Stan's home
being online for months did not
constitute an invasion of privacy then
the very brief Instagram post of Jax
film's Home on sniper Wolf's Instagram
likely doesn't either but that's just
the
law despite what you might have heard on
the the internet YouTube is not the
government and it is not bound by the
First Amendment it is a private party
and it can generally set whatever terms
it wants so even if sniper Wolf's post
didn't rise to the level of criminal
activity the mere Act of doxing the
Douglas home even if the post was later
deleted arguably violated YouTube's
terms of service and could lead to
Sniper Wolf to be deplatformed Andor
demonetized the YouTube's terms of
service prohibit what it describes as
quote harmful behaviors like threats or
doxing now the night that Sniper Wolf
shared an image of the Douglas home
jackfilms tagged YouTube on Twitter
asking the company to demonetize this
dangerous Creator or kick her off the
platform entirely now the next day Jax
film released a video begging YouTube to
enforce its own policies and demonetize
Andor deplatform Sniper Wolf before
someone got hurt and on October 17th Jax
film stated that he had sent YouTube a
video and reiterated his belief that
sniper Wolf's actions constitute a clear
example of doxing and a clear violation
of your policy against threats and
doxing and on October 20th too many
people's disbelief YouTube actually
acted they stated on Twitter confirming
Sniper Wolf has received a temporary
monetization suspension per creative
responsibility policies off-platform
actions that put others personal safety
at risk harm our community and the
behavior on both sides isn't what we
want on YouTube hoping everyone helps
move this convo to a better place uh
this response uh was roundly criticized
because as many people correctly pointed
out uh this is literal both siding that
Jax films had simply created videos
criticizing what he saw as low value
content uh and creating some parities
whereas it was Sniper Wolf that engaged
in the doxing behavior which was a
violation of the terms of service it was
Sniper Wolf who had arguably doxed Jax
films and violated the terms of service
it was not Jax films himself uh who at
least according to the terms of service
has done nothing wrong here and within
the hour Sniper Wolf responded to
YouTube's comment saying let me start by
saying I'm sorry for my recent actions
it is inexcusable I'm sorry to Jax films
YouTube the entire Creator community and
my incredible fans for not being a
better example of appropriate conflict
resolution Jack's film while we
certainly don't see eye to eye in half
our differences I'm sorry for reacting
the way I did when I should have taken
the opportunity to show young creators
how adults and professionals resolve
Conflict by communicating directly
respectfully and privately not for views
or content but a meaningful example of
how conflict should be solved I will
reach out directly and hope we can find
some time to connect and communicate
respectfully I'd also like to thank
YouTube for holding me accountable I
deserve it respect the decision and
appreciate the opportunity to learn and
grow from a true lapse in judgment and
honestly I've seen worst YouTuber
apologies and I hope she does learn from
this moment because even if her actions
didn't rise to the level of being
illegal they were kind of a dick move so
now that sniperwolf has been temporarily
demonetized she'll probably need to find
ways to manage her finances and save
money luckily today's sponsor rocket
money can help cuz sometimes the sponsor
Segways just write themselves now
recently I had a problem trying to get a
handle on all my subscriptions between
my personal and professional
subscriptions I was paying out almost
$20,000 a year in subscriptions and yet
yeah yeah I know these are not all
streaming services being a lawyer is
really expensive and has some very
expensive subscriptions now I hadn't
been paying too much attention to what I
was subscribed to and I couldn't believe
once I started to track my monthly
expenses how much money was going out in
small amounts every month and some of
them were large amounts but rocket money
is an all-in-one Finance platform that
helps you save more and spend less this
personal finance app allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills build
custom budgets and grow your savings all
in one place I'm using rocket money to
help me cancel all the subscriptions I
wasn't using for apps that I hadn't
watched shows on for months and that I
no longer needed now that succession in
Game of Thrones are over rocket money
alerts you of important changes that
impact your score and offers you
insights on ways to improve it it told
me yesterday that a service increase
their price by $100 per year I'll have
to take a look at that and their budget
setting feature is great too I can
automatically monitor my spending by
category I get notifications when I've
exceeded my budgets and I visualize my
spend to earn ratio by month quarter or
year plus rocket money can help you keep
track of your credit and your net worth
so once you canceled all those old
subscriptions you can watch the line go
up and it helps me keep track of my
whole financial picture including cash
debts Investments retirement accounts
collectible items and more so to save
more and spend less join the 3.4 million
members using rocket money today go to
Rocket money.com legal eagal or click on
the link in the description to get
started for free you can also unlock
even more features with premium again
just click on the link that's on screen
right now or down in the description to
get started for free and after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court